p11 portraits signés théophile mbaka et
xavier naizet c'est toujours le même
rituel
il faut revêtir l'habit entrer dans la
peau du sonneur pour faire corps avec
son instrument la trompe de chasse et
instruments qui a traversé les époques
grâce à la chasse à courre en la vénerie
et donc traditionnellement les sonneurs
ont gardé la tenue d' appartenance aux
équipages de chasse à courre par contre
nous avons donc des revers voiliers et
des poches d'une certaine couleur et une
tenue d'une certaine couleur qui crie
qui donne une appartenance à un groupe
de sonneurs devant le miroir pourquoi
parce que en fait on surveille
constamment si notre masque tiens ça
peut elle tenir le match c'est physique
musculairement au niveau des lèvres du
masque dont on a joué on a une telle
pression les certainement vu que en
poussant on va avoir tendance à cette
étape
gonflé donc l'idée c'est de contrôler
visuellement si ça tient bien guyom
volet avait 5 ans quand il a découvert
les 30 de chasse à 8 ans sa vocation
était née
ce sonar à peine trentenaire reste des
prix écume les podiums
quintuple champion du monde de sauna de
trompes face à 500 candidats pour moi
elles ont tous une grande valeur c'est
mon évolution c'est mon histoire
même celles que j'ai remporté la semaine
dernière à lamotte beuvron
elles se ressemblent mais l'histoire
n'est pas la même à chaque fois
sentant que son rêve le rêve c'est de
continuer à pouvoir transmettre ma
passion
il ya dix ans j'avais créé un groupe qui
s'appelle les échos de la jeunesse c'est
motivant pour moi continue de concourir
est resté au plus haut pour montrer
l'exemple à un groupe de jeunes et
maintenant depuis sept ans effectivement
je vis de ma passion et mon rêve c'est
que ça continue plus longtemps possible
quand ils ne répètent pas et quand il ne
donne pas des cours depuis hier volet
s'occupe avec un soin jaloux de ses
instruments
à force il est devenu collectionneur
sonné avec un bel instrument qui brille
de mille feux
une tradition séculaire que guillaume
volet entend faire perdurer